So this Pavlov idea actually is more general than just the prisoner's
dilemma or iterated prisoner's dilemma. And in fact, led to a result that
I like to call the computational folk theorem. The idea of the
computational folk theorem says that you give me any two player, bimatrix game.
>> What's a bimatrix game?
>> Just that there's two players. [LAUGH]
>> Okay. [LAUGH]
>> So it seems kind of redundant, doesn't
it?
>> It does.
>> What makes it bimatrix as opposed to
two player zero sum game which you can
write down with a single matrix, this is
like, each, each player has its own reward matrix.
>> I see.
>> But you're right, I should have, I could've just said bimatrix game and
left out the two player. And it's
an average reward repeated game. So we're going to
play. Rip, Round after round after round.
And we're going to look at the average reward.
Or, you can also think of it
as discounted with an extremely high discount factor.
>> Okay.
>> So
you give me one of those games. And what I
can do is, I can build a Pavlov-like machine for, the,
for any of these games. And use that to construct a
subgame-perfect Nash equilibrium, for any of these games, in polynomial time.
>> Wow.
>> And, so the way that this works is if it is possible for us
to have some kind of mutually beneficial relationship,
then I can build a Pavlov-like machine. Quickly.
If not, the game is actually zero sum like, right? because
in a zero sum game we can't mutually benefit, so we cant
do anything like Pavlov we're just going to beat each other up. So
we can actually solve, linear program in polynomial time, and work out
what the strategies would be if we we're playing a zero sum
like game. And so either that works, and produces a Nash equilibrium,
and we can test that. Or it doesn't work, but at most
one player can improve its behavior. And by taking that best response
against what the other player does in a zero-sum like sense,
then that will be a Nash equilibrium. So there's three possible forms
of the Nash equilibrium. But, we can tick through these, figure out
which one is right and drive the actual strategies in polynomial time.
>> Wow, that's pretty impressive, who came up with this idea?
>> So this is a result due to Peter Stone and somebody, Oh yeah me.
>> Oh, well that's very impressive,
so you managed to find a way to sneak in some of your own work into this class?
>> Here, let's do some more of that.
>> Okay, I'm a big fan. And I think that's
fair because I did that way back when on mimic.
>> Mimic. So, yeah, so what the last topic that, this is,
that's all I really wanted to say about the Folk theorem and repeated
games. What I'd like to do now is move to stochastic games,
which is a generalization of repeating games. And, talk a little bit about
how this relates Back to things like queue learning and MDPs.
>> Oh, okay. That sounds cool, almost sounds like you're wrapping up.
>> It is, that. And that will be the end of, end of the new material.
>> Wow. Well that means we're coming towards the end of the entire course.
>> I know. We're going to all cry with, disappointment.
And I think. And, and I just say this,
you know, as a, as an idle suggestion, that
the students should demand that we teach more classes.
>> I concur. So let's get there so that they can demand.
>> [LAUGH]